huge story is emerging this morning
which has huge implications for the
government and as you said the country
having insisted yesterday that she would
stand firm the Prime Minister and her
Chancellor are expected to decide to
announce that they are not proceeding
with that decision to abolish the top
rate of tax that's the 45 Pence tax rate
it affects one percent of earners those
earning a hundred and fifty thousand
pounds a year they were going to scrap
it from April
2023 next year and as I understand it
they will now not proceed with that
policy it's a massive U-turn even
yesterday as I said the Prime Minister
said we have to stay the course but the
Rebellion not just from back benches but
I think also from within government has
obviously proved too great
okay why have they done this in a great
scheme of things it's not a lot of money
but they weren't reading the room were
they
that's exactly right Kate it wasn't a
lot of money it saved two billion uh in
uh tax Council cost 2 billion rather and
that was in a 45 billion package but uh
it was not consulted upon in uh cabinet
Liz truss uh told the BBC that yesterday
uh and quasi quatang took the decision
one cabinet minister said to me uh it
wasn't right that he hadn't told the
cabinet he should have discussed it more
like widely given uh that it was such a
contentious policy and the political
toxicity if you like of cutting the top
rate of tax with the richest people or
richest earner should I say in the
country amid a cost of living crisis has
prompted a huge uh rebellion and we've
seen it with Michael Gove yesterday uh
publicly coming out saying it should be
opposed and Grant shot so I think uh
you're going to be speaking to soon Kay
saying in a article in the times this
morning that it was an enforced error
harming the government's economic
credibility now those calls are not just
happening outside government they're
happening inside to uh Liz trust
obviously wants to reset the dial she
wants to get rid of
this story this problem this Rebellion
it was going to dominate uh the Party
Conference and they are now I think
preparing to announce that they will not
proceed it's the first massive U-turn of
a government and of a prime minister
that has insisted all along uh that the
political Optics of policies is not her
concern she wants to do what's right
she's told me that she's prepared to be
unpopular this clearly a step too far
and I think it speaks to the fact that
underneath the smooth exterior of this
conference that the conservatives are
trying to portray that there are a lot
of choppy waters on underneath and this
is a prime minister he's now having to
make decisions she might not want to in
order to try and take down the political
temperature okay so she threw the uh
Chancellor under the bus yesterday uh is
the writing on the wall for him now
I think that the chancellor has had a
really difficult start because of this
policy I've asked a lot of people
in the party about that there's no doubt
that they would agree that he has been
embattled but I think the thing that uh
consulters say to me as well is that the
project if you like of this radical
change to economic policy is really
being driven by Liz truss and
quasiquartang in unison uh with the
other two in their economic quad as they
call it which is Simon Clark the
leveling up secretary and Jacob Reese
smog the business secretary and quite
frankly I think lives trust at the
moment is quite politically vulnerable
because she doesn't have a Groundswell
of support in the back benches and some
very very Senior People such as Grant
shaps and Michael gave them making it
difficult for her so however she is
feeling about her Chancellor or tensions
she might decide now it's not the time I
should also say though that I have
pressed uh those around Liz truss about
this sense of tension between her and
her Chancellor and on the issue of the
45 Pence rate of tax I was told
yesterday that the Prime Minister fully
backed uh quasi-quartile's decision uh
to do it even though today they are
reversing so in terms of the outward
perception number 10 is certainly trying
to present it as a union united front uh
between the charts and the Prime
Minister but this is obviously going to
be hugely politically difficult for
quasi-part Tang on the day that he is
delivering his economic speech
on the economy of speech on the economy
in which he was about to say this
afternoon we have to stay the course and
he will kick off the day we expect with
a reversal on that decision to abolish
the top rate of tax the 45 Pence rate
and what does that mean for conference
Beth as a result you made the um point
that it was originally going to be
dominating conference that it was 45
paid out at 40p now I'm guessing it's
going to dominate conference that the
lady was seeing on the screen has
already done a u-turn
I think there's two ways to look at this
um
this was going to dominate conference
even last night when I was talking
uh to to ministers uh to government
figures are they saying well look we can
delay the vote we don't have to vote on
this measure until March next year on
The the abolition of the the rate so we
can buy some time and we can park the
issue but clearly uh the building of the
rebellion led by Michael gave and now
Grant shouts this morning there has been
the political calculation that if they
don't reverse on this policy they can't
get past it at this conference and I I
read it and let's see what they say we
haven't heard anything yet which is what
I understand is going to happen it might
be that they hope that they can uh
reverse this decision today get it over
and done with and then reset and get on
uh with the conference because obviously
politically number 10 and number 11 have
realized that uh with this route going
on through conference it will completely
Dominate and drown out everything else
about I think you're right that the
chancellor and the Prime Minister
haven't been so publicly Resolute in
saying we are not for turning we'll have
a lot of explaining to do today as to
why they are going to change the policy
why today Beth what's happened
well as I said I think there was a big
um there was a big Brewing rebellion and
it was framing uh this whole conference
in a very negative way of a new prime
minister in but a few weeks come into a
conference where I mean the times was
reporting that 14 I hadn't plotted them
all up at 14 MPS were publicly saying
you cannot do this at this point in time
when there's a cost of living crisis and
the other way you can look at this is
that this trust is listening to her back
benches that she will adapt if she sees
that something is not politically viable
so that's one way you could interpret
what they are going to do
but it is no doubt a very difficult
thing to explain when a prime minister
has insisted for the past week that they
will not reverse the policy the
political Rebellion has clearly become
too great and they want to do a U-turn
and hopefully for them quickly move on
yeah but I mean she was Resolute
yesterday on that that she wasn't going
to do that uterine wasn't she Beth and
she was throwing her as I said her
Chancellor under the bus yesterday
morning and now it looks as though she's
on the cusp of changing her mind we
believe an announcement around about 7
30 something like that probably tying in
with the market
um is it down to somebody like Michael
Gove who you mentioned who um is always
he may not be um you know in in the top
echelons of government at the moment but
he is always somebody that is going to
influence at the conservative party
look okay I think I think the thing is
is that if we step back on what's going
on kind of beneath the surface in the
conservative party
let's trusts only one in the first round
of votes from MPS 50 votes she then went
on to win the leadership but she never
won publicly the majority support of the
Parliamentary party and that tells us
that she yes has a very supportive
cabinet and she has a big chunk of the
party that ideologically agree with her
in terms of trying to Turbo but charge
the economy in the way that she is doing
but at the same time if she cannot take
her party with her and is the
conservative infighting continues all
through her first conference when she's
already 33 points down in one poll and
other polls all put in uh the labor
leader and high double digits and even
into 20 points plus if she cannot take
her party then she is in seriously deep
trouble and I think that there has been
a political calculation here that they
do not want this now over the abolition
of the 45 Pence rate which as you said
is a small element of the entire package
of that mini budget to completely swamp
uh this conference I mean one senior
conservative said to me last night it
simply was a mistake the bankers bonus
decision and the top rate of tax were
two relatively small policy
announcements in a massive package but
they have completely distorted the way
in which this budget was received and
the prospect of cutting tax rates for
the highest earners in society when
people are struggling with double digits
inflation the prospects of rising
mortgage rates those high energy bills
even though there is government support
they are still running High
not being able to lift public sector
play with inflation and even a
discussion on whether or not benefits
will be uplifted by earnings rather
inflation rather than inflation it is
really making tours is extremely anxious
it's anxious for their constituents
anxious about the prospects of
re-election and actually for prime
minister who said she had would plow on
overnight clearly she has listened and
taken soundings and realized that she
needs to u-turn on this policy I imagine
they will try and keep it very contained
and quickly move on let's see if they
can